alors vous avez le choix kaléidoscopique
coup qu'il va vraiment pas alors manger
ou saab et une de ses rares oui denise
un premier concurrent et bien ce sera
trouville madame raymonde das ville
raymonde bonjour quel est votre soirée
monde
2500 francs raymond a quoi pensez vous
je pense que la présentation d'une
émission de 1 ira pas dans ton oeil an
plus tôt
madame parfaite comme ça madame marie
qu'un outil qui habite ajaccio en corse
marie bonjour oui pardon halte à un
baldaquin
non ce n'est pas un baldaquin marie
béthune dans le pas-de-calais madame
claudie boulanger claudie bonjour que
c'est pour le plaisir la communication
interne et peut-être encore plus votre
bonheur
mais vous savez mais ils font n'importe
quoi
en tout cas je vous remercie beaucoup
madame que choisissez-vous le
kaléidoscope oui allons j'avais pensé à
tout va bien ce n'était pas pour faire
je la joue là écrivent en cinq jeux
partout aux bijoux de la couronne
toccata premier non non madame ce n'est
pas ça mais monsieur maxime fois de
poitiers maxime bonjour avez vous choisi
maxime pardon oui ça n'est pas ça nico
choisissait bull a maintenant très bien
alors le kaléidoscope et patrese 1500
francs pardon à bon escient car s'il est
célibataire
madame marie claire des veaux qui habite
bonnet dans la saône et loire
marie-claire bonjour votre choix marie
claire marie claude non marie-claude ce
n'est pas un tissu de cash mais merci
monsieur stéphane ados stéphane bonjour
je retenais jeu caribou choisi stéphane
collet plescop annoncé c'est un ensemble
des plus d'oiseaux qui servait aux
indiens comme chapeaux sont des petites
plumes qui permutent attendez vous de me
répéter
oui c'est un ensemble des clips de taro
aso qui servait aux inquiets quand
chapeau non c'est pas ça s'est passé
s'est pas fait stephen madame yvonne pas
exempt yvonne bonjour bonjour demi heure
alors oui le cas les copains oui alors
là ça m'épate à madame suzanne open et
moi pas venir à l'eau qui êtes vous adam
senn bonjour madame
que choisissez vous le kaléidoscope
alors il est à 13 milles 5
alors je pense à un petit monarque
documents non ce n'est pas non plus un
masque de ski mot merci beaucoup
madame monsieur georges trans il est
bonjour messieurs bonjour ballon
continue
pardon madame j'ai choisi le cas l'oeil
des records oui je pense à la carte par
tel prochain
jean qu'il a été investi prince locale
non ce n'est pas ça merci beaucoup mais
ça ne passe à madame danielle guillais
daniel bonjour qu avez-vous choisi oui
alors je pensais à une oreille qui se
trouve à l'intérieur de l'église miniato
à la montée de la région plus rempli non
dans les bassins l'umq monsieur didier
là qu'est didier bonjour pendant tout ce
temps elle est montée à 2100 francs
cette énigme voulez vous que je vous
rappelle la question didier les
frontières naturelles de cette île
mystérieuse ont été empruntés à quatre
pays différents
quelles sont ces pays j'ai dit on fait
ou pas vous choisissez les nigoul
kaléidoscope
oui on a numéroté les les pays
alors à quoi pensez-vous monsieur même
le papillon non ça n'est pas ça madame
brigitte dupont
brigitte bonjour vous plaît oui
écoutez je pointe à une une couronne de
compte
non ce n'est pas une couronne de compte
une aventure
madame bonaventure team nouvelle
aventure pour allô allô
comment vous appelez-vous monsieur j'ai
pas la voiture
oh la la
que choisissez vous monsieur je vous
rappelle la question des frontières
naturelles de cette île mystérieuse été
emprunté à quatre pays différents
quelles sont ces pays il ya quatre pays
monsieur non ça fait 5 mais de toute
façon ça n'est pas ça monsieur
merci beaucoup j'ai le un concurrent
encore gérard et bien c'est monsieur
jean mas manassé liant ninon banon
madina savent tous qu'ils fassent qu'il
faut en face
alors non excusez-moi mais je nous
n'avons plus le temps alors en tout cas
pour jouer avec nous il faut nous écrire
sur cartes postales votre nom votre
numéro téléphone et l'indicatif de votre
département est né nous envoyer cette
carte postale à et maintenant jument
télex france en 75 300 paraît bruit
voilà eh bien c'était notre dernier jeu
de l'après midi oui mais en tout cas moi
je remercie je remercie je vous remercie
tous les deux d'avoir autorisé
non je vous en prie garcimore a beaucoup
ri parce qu'il comprend toujours pas ce
qui se passe parce que vous avez
quelques années mais ne comprend pas le
kaléidoscope pour lui c'est une année
il dit c'est vers ça brille alors ça
alors que des cas alors c'est des
questions concernant le temps de me
revoir les 14 alors là ce serait tout à
fait à la st alexandrine 2 il devra pas
prendre sa seconde là parce qu'il n'a
pas beaucoup de temps sonne très bien
vous allez voir les tracas t-il vous
sortez d'où sort du 04 ça me rappelle
quelque chose c'est qu'il avait déjà
fait mais qu'il y avait eu beaucoup de
lettres des enfants qui voulaient le
voir ce qu'ils disaient qu'il était
délicate dans la mer qui s'était trop
petit qui voyait pas bien alors jury
avait la sphère nouvelle fois et a payé
ou s'expliquer les trichomes il faut
fait est fait comme ça
maintenant qu'on sait c'est vite fait
mais pas comme ça y est tous pas regardé
sauf qu'ils écrivent ils sortent tous
envoyé à l'homme sa masse pas ah oui ça
marche et ça coupe tout seul voilà les
trois quarts qui sont sortis il y en a
ne naîtra alors exceptionnellement
puisque moi explique liam et les trucs
johnny cession-bail et vous expliquer
les trucs de savoir si c'est très facile
c'est pas moi qui fais les flics regarde
c'est pas moi qui le fais c'est à vous
intéresser les servants d'état qui ta ta
ta ta qu'il faut le tout c'est pas moi
oui si vous assistez massivement
charmant ou des noms mertine en
maintenant son dessin qu'on ne réagisse
pas non mais écoutez un cargo qui
souffre en bougeant pourquoi merci mon
cher josé
tous nos compliments cher de neil vous
avez fait gagner aujourd'hui un
téléspectateur
et puis vous avez gardez votre sang
froid si j'ose m'exprimer racing 35
millions prestigieuse est terminée elle
recommencera samedi prochain à la même
heure ce qui nous va bien vers 14h05
14h08 bon week-end sur tf1 au revoir
et nous
et